well i exercise him all the time
the face and the voice of gianna floyd
filling a courtroom
telling the world of a life now without
her father
do you wish that he was still here with
us
yeah but he is
through his spirit yes yes
and when you see your daddy again one
day
what do you want to do when you see him
i
want to play with him
listening to her in court derek chauvin
the man who murdered her father
and who knew he was facing decades in
prison he heard from others
who'd known george floyd the man taken
from them
killed by then officer chauvin's knee on
his neck for more than nine minutes
a murder that sparked protest around the
world and calls for a reckoning in
america
i wanted to know from the man himself
why
what were you thinking what was going
through your head
outside they listened intently those
seeking justice for george floyd
and a sign the system could be fair
inside chauvin's mother spoke on his
behalf
derek has played over and over in his
head the events of that day
i've seen the toll that has taken on him
and then briefly the court heard from
chauvin himself
i do want to give my condolences to the
floyd family
there's going to be some other
information in the future that would be
of interest
and i hope things will give you some
[Music]
some peace of mind 13 months after
george floyd's death
it was judge peter cahill who had the
final word
as a sentence for count one the court
commits you to the custody of the
commissioner of corrections
for a period of 270 months that's 270
that is a 10-year addition to the
presumptive sentence of
150 months this is based on
your abuse of a position of trust and
authority
and also the particular cruelty shown to
george floyd
a sentence of 22 and a half years not
enough for some
for those who knew george floyd though
it is the close of a chapter
it is disappointing uh going into
today i thought it was going to be a
longer sentence i
i i just thought it was going to be 30
or 40 years
that being said all this
would not have happened if it weren't
for
so many people fighting for justice
there is a sense that this has brought
some measure of justice but as
derek chauvin was led away a city and a
country know
there is a long way to go